all right annual Japan q a video let's
just uh get started shinsan what's it uh
what's the experience like moving into a
new house in Japan for the first time
any specific things to take note of my
only advice generally speaking for
moving in Japan is if you're alone
and you don't have that many possessions
moved by yourself but if you're married
hire a moving company don't don't try
and save money hire a moving company
there are multiple moving companies the
way that you want to do it is you want
to call up maybe two or three you get a
an estimate from each and then you you
get them to do like a bidding war and
get lower and lower and lower until you
feel like it's actually like a fair
price the other thing that I wanted to
mention when it comes to moving in Japan
is that in my experience living in
different types of living accommodations
whether that's an apartment or a mansion
or a house at this point
um is that it's you typically don't
really need to do anything
um when you're moving into an apartment
in terms of
greeting the people that you live next
to the thing about apartments of course
is that people come and go right you're
I all the apartments that I had in Japan
I was never in one single place for more
than
more than a a year and a half maybe two
years at the longest and I know that
there are many people that have been in
the same apartment for a long time but
generally speaking you know you're going
to be in there for a limited amount of
time and then you're going to move when
I moved into this house that we have
right now I learned that
and this again kind of makes sense
because you actually own the house and
when you build a house and when you
build a house anywhere again the
assumption is that you are going to be
there for at least a very very long time
and in that sense it's not typically
sufficient just to greet the people that
live on you know immediately next to you
and we actually had to we didn't have to
but I learned that it was customary and
we did do this to buy gifts for every
single person
um on our on our block and this leads me
to a second thing actually I believe
that we went to to those eight or nine
different houses two times once when we
when they started doing construction to
say hey we're moving into this house um
uh or we're building this house sorry
it's going to be loud for a little while
and then again after we officially moved
in just keep in mind that if you like to
keep to yourself if you're more of an
introvert a house might not be the best
option for you in Japan because it
inherently 99 of cases is going to
require you to interact with people much
more than something like an apartment
okay being being vegan in Japan a
question mark and then there's a
question about uh duolingual Duolingo as
well I'm not going to answer the
Duolingo question because I've never
used that app but I was a vegan like a
full proper vegan for about three years
in Japan these days I also eat fish and
I also eat eggs fairly regularly and
then every now and then if I'm like with
like a YouTube Buddy
um and you know we go out to dinner or
something like that and there's not a
vegan option there then I don't have a
major qualm with like you know eating
meat in in that particular setting but
the one thing that I can say and this is
going to get into a little bit more of a
deeper topic but it is significantly
harder to be a vegan in Japan than it is
in the United States and one of the
reasons for that is because vegan
culture in general is just a much more
it is a much newer thing in Japan than
it is in the United States one of my
general rules of thumb for life in Japan
in general is that everything that
becomes popular in the United States
becomes popular in Japan five to ten
years later what I really want to talk
about in this talk when it comes to
Health in Japan in general Japan
actually allows a lot of
what's the term
like pesticides as well as food
preservatives that are actually no
longer allowed in a lot of other First
World countries so I know that
there are a lot of strawberry farms in
Japan that use what's considered outside
of Japan to be a very dangerous
pesticide
I don't know if it's if it's a pesticide
or I don't think the the term fertilizer
is correct it's some kind of chemical
that either keeps the bugs away or it
either makes the plants grow uh faster
either way it's considered outside of
Japan to be a very dangerous chemical
and because of this Japan can't export
these strawberries to countries such as
the United States like they're legally
not allowed to because America because
these chemicals in the United States are
completely outlawed and that was pretty
shocking for me to learn trans fats I
believe are not allowed in food in the
United States as well so like when I was
growing up I always had peanut butter
that one of the ingredients was
partially hydrogenated soybean oil so
hydrogenated fats I believe
um or hydrogenated oils I believe that
they are no longer allowed in the United
States because there was a bunch of
evidence that came out that said this is
really really bad for you and so the
United States the FDA I guess they said
we can't have this it's gone but these
are still allowed in Japan actually and
this is particularly true for
convenience store Foods so I'm very very
sad to be the one to break this news to
everyone because I know myself included
I love convenience store food so much
but
um for the past like two or three years
I haven't I've barely touched any of the
junk food in convenience stores because
I know how how bad it is for me so like
I go to convenience stores all the time
because they're extremely convenient in
Japan and they've got a lot of great
options that don't contain all these
food preservatives plain hard-boiled
eggs and then maybe a bag of
um what do you say plain nuts so no oils
or anything like that but like if you're
if you if you're having like you know uh
these like
fluffy egg sandwiches or like the peanut
butter like uh sandwiches that are in
the bags or essentially any kind of food
you know like the metal and pong all the
kinds of like Breads and donuts and
stuff like that that they have in
convenience stores
I can almost guarantee you that that
stuff is
loaded with stuff that's that's not
healthy I'm not trying to say like Japan
is really bad like
I'm saying that some of the options that
are available
are dangerous but if you just choose
something else you'll be you can you can
be very healthy it's just you once you
have to have the knowledge right so I'm
trying to just spread knowledge okay
what is Healthcare like in Japan how
expensive is it if we zoom out to like a
macro level Japanese Healthcare is quite
good and what I mean by that is
It's relatively cheap especially if you
can compare it uh it's relatively cheap
for most people especially if you can
compare it to like the U.S health uh
Healthcare Obamacare I forget what it's
called
um or like various private insurance
plans that they have in in the United
States or other countries
um and
generally speaking most hospitals have
pretty good equipment as well so like
it's pretty easy to get an MRI for
Fairly cheap in Japan
um so that's you know that's a wonderful
thing right it's very very good for a
lot of things but it's also it can be a
little bit tricky for other things and
what I mean by this is that of course
one of the issues that Japan is facing
right now is the depopulation crisis
right and my experience is that every
single time that I visit a hospital
I have to wait a very very very long
time
primarily because well obviously because
there are so many old people there and
old people naturally have more health
conditions than young people do there's
a lot of old people in hospitals that
are there just because they're worried
even if they don't have an issue and a
lot of doctors immediately recognize
this and I think that they've become
slightly jaded because of this again if
you see like five or success patients in
a row and they're all like
doctor I'm I feel like something's wrong
I'm you know
but I I don't know exactly what I just
want to make sure that I'm okay you know
kind of like for the peace of mind then
that might be a little bit frustrating
aggravating for a doctor and you might
get a little bit jaded because of that
but if that ends up affecting your
judgment for people that actually have
serious health issues then that's a
dangerous thing so I've had my fair
share of experiences where I waited two
hours or maybe three hours to see a
doctor that didn't really care about me
and just gave me some like medicine that
didn't help at all and then I ended up
having to go to a different doctor a
better doctor later on because again my
issue didn't get any better hopefully
that's a beneficial information for some
of the people out there okay next
question okay so Marcos says taxes okay
which is the only certain thing together
with death yeah indeed two things I'd
like to mention here one thing very
briefly the one thing being that if
you're a foreigner in Japan and you're
trying to figure out taxes by yourself
don't just hire a professional a good
accountant will always pay by pay for
themselves the other thing that I want
to say is that because I don't think
I've talked about this in detail before
is that of course because of the
depopulation crisis and because of
the economic stagnation they're
interconnected of course very much so
but they're also there are many economic
issues that don't deal so much with uh
the older generation the older
generation is a tremendous stress on the
Japanese economy but it's not the only
reason that the Japanese economy isn't
doing so hot right now one of the main
reasons as far as I can tell is a
general lack of innovation think about
all the really popular smartphone
companies right what do you have you
have American companies South Korean
companies and you have Chinese companies
you know uh Apple you've got Samsung
we've got xiaomi uh is it Wowway
um and maybe there's like one Japanese
company that might come to mind which
would be Sony and Sony makes Incredible
smartphones I love Sony as a company I
think that they're they're incredible
um and they're the smartphones that they
make are they're technical Marvels they
they stand their own they stand their
ground when compared to iPhones or any
other you know smartphone for that
matter but their share of the market is
quite low compared to of course like
Apple or Samsung think about all the
apps that you use as well they're either
you know like Snapchat or Facebook or
Instagram or Twitter you know Silicon
Valley apps or Tick Tock right so again
it's like America and in China point
that I'm trying to make here when it
comes to taxes is that the Japanese
economy is not doing so hot right now
and more and more young people each year
are
pain into the pension system such that
the older people can get the Social
Security that they paid into when they
were young but because of the
demographics and because of the economic
situation this system is getting is
getting very very stressed I've heard
one argument against this that says
that's not true if if you if you make
young people aren't bearing the burden
of this in a disproportionate way like
if you look at the amount of money that
the average young person gets taxed it's
not that high and this is actually true
as far as I can tell that being said
the average or the the young person that
makes the that makes
above the average amount of money gets
taxed significantly in the 10 years or
so that I've been in Japan not only have
what do you say consumption tax sales
tax yeah sales taxes have gone from
three percent to five percent to eight
percent to ten percent they're probably
going to go up again but in addition to
that income taxes as well particularly
for the upper brackets have increased
pretty dramatically as well so
um just in the couple of years that I've
been doing YouTube the percentage of my
income that I pay into taxes each year
has has gone up expect to pay a lot in
taxes if you're doing well in Japan I
don't want to be too redundant on this
point any advice for landing a job after
alt work currently on jet curious to see
if you have any recommendations as I'm
trying to extend my stay past my
teaching tenure three to four years from
now would love to land somewhere in
localization this is something that I've
also been meaning to talk talk about for
a while AI is so disruptive right now in
Japan that I think translation for sure
is not a market that I would encourage
people to get into the reason being that
even if you say well yes but translation
translators are always going to be
wanted for things like fiction right
there's going to be a lot of authors
that refuse to use AI because they want
a human to translate their book or their
movie or whatever it might be and that's
probably true for the overwhelming
majority of cases however
there's already a ton of translators and
interpreters that are already beginning
to lose work because of AI well I just
believe that you you won't want to get
into that market because it's going to
be so competitive
um and the point that I'm trying to make
here is that I was pretty confident in
recommending a different a variety of
different ways of searching for work in
Japan maybe like four or five years ago
I would say you know I think programming
is a pretty safe bet I think that um
these are things I said in the past
again I think programming is a pretty
safe bet I think that uh YouTube and
like uh twitch are actually pretty good
for people that are more creative
creative and um these days I frankly I
just don't know Apple just announced a
uh Apple Vision Pro and by the time that
that gets to its fourth or fifth
generation the world is just going to
look completely different it's going to
be an even bigger leap than the pre and
post smartphone Revolution right
uh because AR and VR is going to provide
so many fundamentally different
experiences than this you know four
cornered screen that we were used to
looking at whether it's a tablet or a
computer or a phone in that sense I
think that probably the safest thing to
do I'm not trying to say that this is is
the funnest the most fun thing to do or
what you should personally be doing but
probably the the most secure option is
to do something that involves AR or VR
whether that's programming specifically
for that or developing specifically for
for that or you could try and get on
like a creative team at a company like a
a media company I know that Disney's
trying to lean in uh Disney was in
Apple's like keynote as well and they
said we're already working on like this
3D content so there's probably a bunch
of Studios right now that are going to
be focused on 3D expansive content and
so that in my mind I don't know if this
is going to turn out true or not but
that seems like probably the safest
route if career security job security
isn't the most important thing to you
when it comes to work in general but
you're still looking for work advice
working in Japan advice I would say try
and become an expert at three different
things corrupt politician says what are
some of your favorite Japanese films I
really like uh
I think that's how you pronounce his
name I shouldn't say that I'm a big fan
of his in general because I've seen more
movies of his that I don't like than
movies of his that I do like
but at the same time two of my favorite
Japanese movies were both directed by
him one being audition
and the other being 13 assassins he also
did I think
Ichi the killer yeah he did Ichi the
killer um as well if you explore his his
library at large besides just the stuff
that gets you know picked up by the
media because how
crazy it is then you'll you can find
movies like 13 assassins which is
it has a lot of Gore more Gore than the
typical like uh R-rated movie which is
already saying a lot but it's just a
phenomenal phenomenal movie okay Randy
says why is famichiki uh the best
kombini fried chicken this relates to
what I said earlier when we foreigners
talk about uh Japanese convenience
stores uh the general consensus is look
how amazing this is everything is so fun
everything is so good everything is is
wonderful and again Japanese convenience
stores can be wonderful and they are uh
extremely convenient but I'm quite
terrified of uh what kind of oils that
they might be using in funny chicken
please be careful okay so Anthony lamb
has asked a very interesting question
which
it's quite long so I can't read this
whole thing but he's essentially saying
that okay we've seen how Japanese the
culture surrounding Japan has changed
over the recent years through against
streaming services and other tools and
the internet in general but how do you
envision Japanese culture changing Japan
is in Dire Straits right now we talked
about this earlier in this video we
talked about how the Japanese economy
isn't doing so well and there's proof of
this and like the smartphone market we
talked about how a lot of the foods uh
the ingredients that are in a lot of
food products aren't that great and of
course the swelling pension system and
the depopulation crisis increasing taxes
it's probably you know sales tax is
probably going to go up again soon in
the near future
what does Japan have in store
um and I think that there's two two ways
you could look at this it's either the
glass is half full or the glass is
half empty of course and I think that
the more pessimistic argument is that
Japan has no future
this equation of
variables when it comes to the Japanese
economy and the demographic the Japanese
population like this is a recipe for
disaster no country can get out of this
situation
um and those that have have only done so
by accepting a lot of immigrants I I
think that Germany might be a successful
example of this is Germany or maybe it
was it France I can't remember exactly I
apologize if I'm getting that wrong but
of course Japan is kind of notorious for
not accepting a ton of foreigners each
year it's uh relatively speaking Japan
is still extremely
a Japanese country again the more
pessimistic argument is
Japan will never change and get out
while you can kind of and we've actually
seen this with a fair number of young
successful
not even young just successful people
leaving Japan there's a lot of Japanese
people that
um once they become a little bit
successful they end up moving out of
Japan because either the taxes are so
much or because the future is brighter
outside of Japan it's maybe the best way
to say it is what they seem to think or
if they didn't believe that they'd still
be in Japan right
and I think that there's a lot of
evidence that that may very well happen
but I'm actually of the argument that of
the belief that Japan will be able to
get through this
um it may take 50 years and there's
probably going to be a lot of growing
pains but the reason that I'm personally
optimistic is because of Japanese
culture and the history of Japan at
large in the last Japan q a video that I
made I talked about how
um Japan I talked about the non-climega
thrust earthquake how Japan I believe
the statistic was 25 of all earthquakes
that occur in the world occur in or
immediately uh around Japan because
Japan is on I believe three separate
tectonic plates and every 300 years
Japan gets hit by this non-climega
thrust earthquake which is imagine the
311 earthquake that we saw 10 years ago
11 years ago
um
12 years ago anyway imagine that only
occurring
in a an even more spread out location
because the it'll happen across multiple
tectonic plates as opposed to just a
single one so Japan is expected to get
hit by this this massive earthquake in
the relatively near future if you look
at Japanese history it has happened
every 300 years for as long as there's
data available the point that I'm trying
to make is Japan's still here
right the Japan that all of us love that
I love is still here Japan has been hit
by
so many disasters uh over and over and
over again and every single time
arguably speaking they've been able to
Rise From the Ashes and make something
even better you can say that about the
earthquakes
um maybe another example of this though
is and I'm going to try and tread
lightly here because uh this is a
sensitive topic but is
post-world War II Japan was not in good
shape after World War II and of course
uh the Americans came in they had their
occupation for a little bit but in very
little time Japan ended up ended up
becoming the world's number two
superpower Japan seems to be actually
pretty good at rising from the ashes and
um making it out the other end and I do
think that
um things are going to get a lot worse a
lot worse before they ever get better
um but I'm prepared to
right through it and I'm particularly
optimistic that the younger generation
of Japanese people like my daughters are
going to be extremely tough and
resilient and because they're going to
grow up during probably a relatively
difficult time
and so I think that if
I think that Japan will get through this
and that when they do that young strong
resilient generation will be able to
make Japan even better I'm putting my
chips in that direction I'm optimistic
for the future of Japan and hopefully
that's a a bright note to end the video
on I'm just going to ramble if I don't
so thank you for watching the video and
I'll talk to you guys again soon
foreign